the amount of data in the world is guess
what it's growing exponentially if that
is doubling about every couple of years
or so and that's set to continue for a
long long time to come as we instrument
our cities as we have the Internet of
Things as we instrument our bodies as we
gather more data and that will fuel this
revolution in machine learning you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using dr.
Christopher Bishop is quite a fellow
literally fellow of the Royal Academy of
Engineering fellow of Darwin College in
Cambridge England fellow of the Royal
Society of Edinburgh fellow of the Royal
Society
Microsoft technical fellow and one of
the nicest fellows you're likely to meet
he's also director of the Microsoft
research lab in Cambridge where he
oversees a world-class portfolio of
research and development endeavors in
machine learning and AI today dr. Bishop
talks about the past present and future
of AI research explains the no free
lunch theorem talks about the modern
view of machine learning for how he
learned to stop worrying and love
uncertainty and tells how the real
excitement in the next few years will be
the growth in our ability to create new
technologies not by programming machines
but by teaching them to learn that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Chris Bishop welcome to the podcast it's
great to be here
you are quite a fellow literally in
broad strokes what gets a fellow like
you up in the morning what does the day
in the life of Chris Bishop look like
great question if I had to summarize my
work life in one word I'd say it's
varied I have to do many many different
things of course think about the
strategy for the research lab think
about research directions recruitments a
very big part of what I do really
finding great talent and then looking
after the career development of people
that we've hired nurturing that great
talent I think a lot about inclusion and
diversity but also thinking about our
external visibility giving presentations
engaging with universities engaging with
customers but also scanning the horizon
thinking about new opportunities for us
so no two days are ever the same well
ask the lab director of MSR Cambridge in
Cambridge England not to be confused
with Cambridge Massachusetts over here
right give our listeners a sense of the
vision for the work in your lab and what
constitutes what you call thought
leadership in AI today yeah that's a
great question the field of AI is really
evolving very rapidly and we have to
think about what the implications are
and not just a few years ahead but even
further beyond I think one thing that
really characterizes the MSR Cambridge
research lab is that we have a very
broad and multidisciplinary approach so
we have people who are real-world
experts in the algorithms of machine
learning and engineers who can turn
those algorithms into scalable
technology but we also have to think
about what I call the sort of penumbra
of research challenges that sit around
the algorithms issues to do with
fairness and transparency issues to do
with adversary's because know if it's a
publication nobody's going to attack
that but if you if you put out of
service to millions of people then there
will be bad actors in the world who will
attack it in various ways and so we now
have to think about AI and machine
learning in this much broader context of
large-scale real world applications and
that requires people from a whole range
of disciplines we need designers we need
social science
a whole spectrum of different talent and
those people have to come together and
collaborates I think that's quite a
special feature of the MSR cambridge lab
so on the work that's happening in
machine learning how are you pushing the
boundaries when it comes to developing
and furthering this science of machine
learning and artificial intelligence so
really we take a very bottom-up view and
that we hire very smart creative people
and give them a lot of flexibility to go
and explore the many different frontiers
of machine learning but part of it too
comes back to this multidisciplinary
approach so one of the areas for example
that we're very interested in is
confidential machine learning machine
learning of course is fuelled by data
and we know that data is precious we
need to protect it it may be very
personal nature of its health care data
for example and so how can we make sure
that the technology has access to the
data but at the same time preserve the
appropriate levels of privacy and then
what technologies can we create to
support that and so we need to bring
together people who understand the
algorithms with people who understand
security and privacy and the engineering
skills as well to create viable scalable
technologies that we can actually use in
the real world let's talk about you for
a second
you started out in physics and then move
to computer science what prompted that
move and how do you see the two fields
complementing each other in what's going
on in computer science today right yes I
started out in physics as you say
because as a teenager I was just
fascinated by quantum mechanics and
relativity and it was a very exciting
time in physics so I actually did a PhD
in Edinburgh with David Wallace and
Peter Higgs in quantum field theory and
after that I wanted to do something more
applied and I worked on the fusion
program so that's the challenge of
hitting hydrogen up to hundreds of
millions of degrees and getting it to
fuse into helium much as happens in the
Sun and one day will crack that and that
will give humanity unlimited amounts of
clean energy but there's still a long
way off but while I was working on that
of course I developed a lot of expertise
in certain kinds of mathematics in
particular linear algebra and continuous
math multivariate calculus and
probabilities and it turns that
that those are just the kinds of math
skills you need for machine learning in
fact much more so than traditional
computer science because traditional
computer science is really based on
logic and determinism
whereas machine learning requires
continuous maths and dealing with
uncertainty and so physics actually
turns out to be a pretty good starting
point for machine learning in terms of
how I made the switch that's actually
quite interesting I was working on the
fusion program and Hinton published his
paper on neural nets on back propagation
and it got quite a bit of attention and
I thought this sounds pretty interesting
I've never really been interested in
traditional to heating in the sense of
telling a machine what to do step by
step and how to do it step by step but
the idea that a machine could learn from
experience so that it could acquire its
own intelligence was just incredibly
fascinating and so when this research
was published I got very interested I
persuaded my boss to buy me a
workstation I told myself had a program
got some software and started to play
about with these neural networks and the
first thing I did with the neural nets
was to apply them to data from the
fusion program because I was working
there in Oxford on the world's biggest
fusion experiment in its day it was the
big data of the day very high frequency
high spatial resolution Diagnostics huge
amounts of data pouring off lots of
interesting data analysis problems and I
found myself almost uniquely in that
field in possession of this rather
flexible nonlinear technique of neural
nets and so I published a lot of papers
solved all our problems in that space
had great fun for a couple of years and
then decided this field was so
interesting that I actually wanted to
move out of physics and actually do
machine learning full-time I was nearly
30 years ago now well let's talk about
MSR Cambridge you've been there from the
beginning and you said at one point that
you've noted over the years that
progress in artificial intelligence and
machine learning has been both much
slower and much faster than you expected
right so what do you mean by that okay
so I think the reality the underlying
reality is that progress has been
actually been relatively steady and
quite good but the perception of it is
that nothing much happened for a very
long time and then suddenly it all took
off and I think what
happened is that there was some
particular development specifically
around multi-layer neural net so-called
deep learning which allowed ideas that
have already been around for quite a
long time to improve in accuracy to the
point where they became of great
practical value and this was noticed
particularly in speech recognition and
also in certain image analysis problems
detecting objects in images for example
and the qualitative improvement in
performance across the threshold at
which these techniques became of great
practical relevance and so he went from
a world where I would have said
insufficient attention was being paid to
machine learning you had a lot of
potential and yet it was sort of being
ignored and was rather frustrating and I
were almost in the opposite situation
where there's this huge amount of
attention excitement around it we're
kind of running just to keep up the
middle child is getting attention
finally so that's right you once said
that being a researcher is better than
being a rockstar I don't know if you
remember that but it was funny I started
laughing so what do you know that Mick
Jagger doesn't and why do you feel
research is so rewarding well I find it
strange that I said things I'm not
entirely sure what it's like to be a
rock star but I can tell you what's
great about being a researcher and it's
the fact that every day is new by
definition in research you always do new
things there's no point being the second
person to discover something and so you
have that sort of endless variety that
will last an entire career and I always
think it's just wonderful to be in a
field where you're always doing new
things it's always fresh rather than
doing the same thing over and over again
so for me that's just one of the great
things about research and also another
great aspect about being a researcher as
a career is that there's this ocean of
possibilities I may have been quite
lucky and I've worked in very abstract
theoretical physics my PhD I worked on a
very applied area fusion research for a
while then switched into machine
learning and with in machine learning
I've been interested for a while in
algorithms then I've shifted my interest
more to applications there's this
infinite ocean of possibility and so
this is why I think people don't retire
because why would you it's just so
interesting and there's more to be done
and always
things to explore
[Applause]
[Music]
I would propose that every field is
searching for its own version of a
silver bullet or a grand theory of
everything and for AI some people have
suggested that there might be a
universal algorithm for machine learning
should researchers be spending any time
on that and if not what should we be
looking for instead that's a really
interesting question so there's this
theorem in machine learning as a
wonderful name is called the no free
lunch theorem I love it
it basically says that if you look at
all possible problems that you might
apply machine learning to then on
average any algorithm is just as good or
bad as any other in other words the
theorem says there cannot be a single
Universal machine learning algorithm
that will solve all problems now let me
be a little bit careful because it's a
piece of abstract theory so it's correct
we've got to be careful when we
interpret it because it may be that
there are certain algorithms that are
very good at solving all the kinds of
problems that we're going to encounter
in the real world so it may be that
techniques like deep neural networks are
really quite generic and broadly
applicable however what the no free
lunch theorem does teach us is that you
cannot learn just from data you learn
from data in the context of assumptions
or they're sometimes called prior
knowledge or constraints the terminology
varies but it's data in the context of a
model or set of assumptions that allows
you to learn allows the machine to learn
and those assumptions are dependent on
the particular problem you're solving so
what it means is that instead of
searching for the single universal
algorithm that will solve all problems
instead you need to think about the
particular problem that you're trying to
solve and finding the best technique and
that involves thinking about the
assumptions you want to make or the
domain knowledge well let's talk about
the concept of uncertainty for a minute
I had a researcher on the show a couple
weeks ago and he talked about sometimes
we need to embrace the idea of well
calibrated uncertainty in complex
autonomous systems so how might we work
to quantify uncertainty this is really
fundamental to machine learning I call
it the modern view of machine learning
so traditionally we thought of machine
learning as a kind of a
function that you fitted to some data by
fitting a curve through data so that you
could make predictions where you tune up
the parameters so that the neural net
gets it right on the training set if you
hope that it works on the test set and I
think there's a broader view of machine
learning in which we say that what's
really happening is the machine is
building a model of the world and that
model of the world is quantified through
uncertainty and the unique calculus of
uncertainty is probability and so the
machine is built on probabilities and
its understanding of the world carries
uncertainty but as it sees more data
that uncertainty typically will reduce
so it becomes less uncertain in other
words it's learned something is learned
from the data and that notion is all
captured in a very elegant piece of
mathematics called Bayes theorem and so
I viewed Bayes theorem and the
quantification of uncertainty through
probabilities as being the bedrock of
machine learning and from that
everything else can follow so I agree I
think it's totally fundamental to the
field so you've used a phrase
model-based machine learning is that
what you're talking about here right the
idea of model-based machine learning is
really taking that idea of prior
knowledge or constraints domain
knowledge and making that a first-class
citizen think of it less as being a
specific technique think of it more as a
viewpoint a way of understanding what
machine learning is about so imagine
you're a newcomer to the field of
machine learning the first thing you
discover is that there are thousands and
thousands and thousands of papers with
hundreds or thousands of different
algorithms with lots of different names
it's like you're at sea without a
compass do you have to read all those
papers do you have to understand them
all you want to solve some practical
problem that you can't possibly be
familiar with all of the different
techniques so what are you going to do
well instead you can adopt this model
based viewpoint of the model-based
viewpoint says think about the
assumptions that you want to make in
your machine learning solution and
actually write them down be explicit
about it and then translate those
assumptions into a model so the model is
just a mathematical representation of
your assumptions and you can then
combine that with the data and then when
you turn the crank the machine will
learn
you've made good assumptions the machine
will learn very efficiently from the
data so if you're able to make strong
assumptions and they're correct you get
a lot more information out of the same
amount of data the risk though is that
if you make a strong assumption and it's
wrong then not only can the machine make
bad predictions but it can be very
confident about those bad predictions so
you have to be careful so we're in the
middle of what many people are calling
an AI revolution and you've suggested
that we're seeing machine learning uh
sure in a sort of Moore's Law of data
even as we see Moore's law in the
traditional sense sort of on the wane
but it's changing the way that we write
software can you tell us a bit more
about what we're seeing at the
revolution yet love to talk about this
it's really a viewpoint on all the hype
and excitement that we have right now
around artificial intelligence so the
term artificial intelligence for me
refers to that grand aspiration that
very long term goal of producing human
level intelligence and beyond we're a
long way from that so you might ask well
does that mean that all this excitement
around AI is just misplaced or is just
way too early that it's just a hype
bubble it will go away and I say not I
think there is something happening which
is very profound and very
transformational and it's not to do with
artificial intelligence it's to do with
a revolution in the way we create
technology so I can explain that by
analogy with hardware so you need
hardware you need software to build
technology in the hardware if you think
about computers over the years all the
time
hardware is getting faster and cheaper
and better and that progression though
is not linear it was sort of linear up
until a certain moment when a particular
technology was created called
photolithography and that allows us to
print transistors so instead of
manufacturing the components of a
computer than assembling them instead
you print the whole circuit in one go on
a silicon chip and that was profound
because it switched the progression to
exponential and that's Moore's law and
everything else follows the existence of
Microsoft the fact that you have a
supercomputer in your pocket all follows
from Moore's law so I think we're seeing
in the so-called AI revolution which is
really a machine learn
revolution a similar singular moment in
the history of software so go back to
the beginnings of software Ada Lovelace
she was the world's first software
developer and she wrote software for
Babbage's analytical engine she had to
specify exactly what every gear wheel
did at every moment
software developers today is sort of
much the same but they're much more
productive but nevertheless software
developers today still have to tell the
Machine how to solve the problem their
bottleneck is the human intellect but
with machine learning we have a
radically different way of creating
software because instead of programming
the machine to solve the problem we
programmed the machine to learn and then
we train it using data the rate-limiting
step now is the fuel that powers machine
learning it's the data so we write these
machine learning algorithms the computer
can learn from experience and now we
train it using data and what's really
interesting is that the amount of data
in the world is guess what it's growing
exponentially if that is doubling about
every couple of years or so and that's
set to continue for a long long time to
come as we instrument our cities as we
have the Internet of Things as we
introduced as we gather more data and
that will fuel this revolution in
machine learning which is why I think
the hype around artificial intelligence
is not incorrect you just misplaced the
real excitement for the next few years
is going to be this exponential growth
in our ability to create new
technologies not by programming machines
but by having them learn
[Music]
let's come back to health care I know
this is a passion of yours
so talk about some of the strategies
you're working on to improve healthcare
with AI and m/l healthcare is possibly
the biggest opportunity of all for
machine learning but it's a very very
difficult field in which to work and in
many ways healthcare as an industry is
still in a relatively primitive State
compared to some areas of manufacturing
or other sectors the healthcare industry
still buys fax machines for example
which is extraordinary I didn't realize
that fax machines were still being
manufactured but they are and it's the
health industry that buys them so in a
way before we even think about machine
learning in healthcare we have to think
about the digital transformation of
healthcare and of my personal medical
records are probably stored on bits of
paper scattered across various different
cities in the UK according to where I've
lived and so on we first of all have to
think about digital transformation of
healthcare and then we can think about
the machine learning that builds on top
of it so it's a bit of a long-term bet
on the other hand the societal benefit
that could come by taking a more
evidence driven approach to healthcare
is phenomenal
one of the things that it can allow is
the potential for personalized
healthcare because we're individuals
personalized healthcare though is
something if we're to deliver that at
scale it's got to be done in an
automated way machine learning offers
that potential in just the same way that
a machine can learn your preferences for
movies it can learn what would be an
appropriate course of treatment for you
as an individual but it can only do that
by learning about the patterns that
occur in large numbers of people so by
analyzing data from millions of people
we have the potential to create
personalized health solutions for each
of those people as individuals I call it
the paradox of personalization so in
terms of the strategies we come with two
things but really only two things one is
our cloud technology and the other is
our machine learning expertise but for
everything else we need to work in
partnership so all of our healthcare
work is done in collaboration with
medics with collisions we work with
local hospitals actually hospitals
around the world bringing together
domain experts from the healthcare
sector with machine learning experts
jointly to work on solution
if we have personalized healthcare
that's digital or you know machine
learning based where does that put the
doctor how much of this is maybe going
to displace medical professionals any
there's always a question asked about
whether machine learning will replace
people or whether it will help them one
particular project we're working on is
using machine learning to find the
boundaries in three dimensions of tumors
brain tumors for example in order to be
able to use that information for
radiation therapy learning now this is a
job which is ideal for a machine because
the machine can do it very much faster
than the human with less variability
more accurately and the clinicians that
we work with the radiation oncologists
love this technology they're very
excited to have it because this is a
part of their job which is tedious and
time-consuming but they have to get it
right they have to pay attention to the
detail so they're excited to work with
us to help to create tools that will
allow them to do that piece of their job
more effectively to free up time to do
things that machines aren't very good at
of course you need the machine to know
where the tumor is in order to plan the
radiation therapy but you also need a
conversation with somebody about whether
you want that therapy or not what are
the outcomes going to be what are the
implications going to be for you and
your family you've got to make these
complex decisions and I for one wouldn't
want to do that by interacting with an
app I would like to talk to a clinical
expert and really understand based on
their experience but also on their human
empathy what is the best path forward
for me circling back to the healthcare
issue and the big data what's your take
on how we can work to protect privacy
and Trust then in a world where big
datasets are essential to machine
learning and data is even a new form of
currency this is a really important
issue and part of it is technical but
part of it is more general somebody told
me the other day of a lovely Portuguese
expression apparently which says that
Trust arrives on foot but it leaves on a
horse meaning that its hard-won but
easily lost so Trust is not just about
technology it's about perception and
it's about the confidence that people
have in the technology that's
though technology can help with some
aspects of trust so in particular one of
the areas we're working on in the MSR
cambridge research lab we call
confidential machine learning and the
idea is to be able to take data which
normally would be protected by
encrypting it so it's scrambled in a way
that others can't access if you don't
have the keys to that standard and it
would be stored in an encrypted form
again that standard practice but now
when you want to process that data for
example you want to use it as the fuel
for machine learning then you have to
decrypt the data once the data is
decrypted it becomes vulnerable to
attack so the technology that we've been
developing and it's been deployed on
Azure the Microsoft cloud allows for the
data to be decrypted only inside what I
call secure enclaves he's a very tightly
controlled software environment
protected with certain hardware
technologies making them very secure and
meaning that only those with access to
the keys the data could ever access the
data itself even when it's being
processed not just when it's being
stored even to the extent that microsoft
itself can't access the data of its
customers if it's being decrypted inside
these secure enclaves
so that's a kind of technology which can
help to retake the most valuable kinds
of data but it's not enough just to have
the technology you need to have the
trust but it's important I think also to
understand the benefits that can arise
from the application of data to machine
learning so that we are able as a
society to find the right balance
between how we use data and how we
protect data because at one extreme we
don't want a free-for-all where data is
readily available to everybody when it's
really private on the other hand we
don't want to miss out on the enormous
opportunity to improve lives and save
lives that could come through applying
machine learning in fields like health
care so technology can help but it's by
no means the complete solution so let's
talk about talent you've said that
you're looking for researchers that not
only are the world's best but also fit
with our values how would you define
those values in other words what kind of
incentives can any company offer top
reach
Searchers now that's a great question
because there is a tremendous
competition right now for top talent in
the field of machine learning what I
would say to somebody going into the
field or somebody who's on the job
market and thinking about coming to
Microsoft and particular to Microsoft
research is to say that we have this
great combination of on the one hand the
opportunity to have a lot of freedom and
to set the direction of your search and
to go after things that you're
particularly excited about but at the
same time mechanisms to take the output
of your research and get them out there
into the real world so the people that I
really want to attract are those who
want to go after really hard deep
challenging research problems but with a
view to the output of their research
being used to make the world a better
place but actually to see that work
being used at scale and that's one of
the great things about Microsoft is that
we can reach hundreds of millions or
even billions of people with our
technologies we're at a stage now where
we have unprecedented compute power we
have huge data sets and sophisticated
algorithms but I'm hearing that people
in the field are starting to recognize
that we need more than computer
scientists to solve them so is that true
and if so talk about the trend toward
this interdisciplinary approach to
problem solving sure so that's
definitely been worth the
transformations in the field over the
last thirty years for the first 25 years
or so that I've been in machine learning
the goal was to get the error rate down
to have the performance of the algorithm
be sufficiently good that it was
interesting and so that was really all
that anybody was focused on but now that
the error rates are low now that the
algorithms are working on real-world
problems with high accuracy and
therefore becoming of great interest for
practical application we now have to
explore and understand a whole swathe of
new research problems that arise when
you take that out with them and you put
that in the real world so first of all
there's going to be an end user and that
user will have some sort of experience
and they're not gonna want to engage
directly with an algorithm there'll be
some sort of user interface some kind of
the user experience so having designers
who can design that
user experience is crucial but also we
need social scientists who can
understand the way in which people
engage with the technology that opens up
many research challenges that need to be
explored we need to think about
adversarial attacks on the AI and how to
defend against those again that opens up
a whole range of research challenges we
need to think about explanations and you
don't want an explanation expressed in
terms of mathematics of Europe just a
regular end-user you need something
expressed in normal language that you
can understand so how do we go to
address that and then one of the real
challenges is getting people from
different fields working successfully
together because they often have
different cultures and different
language and different terminology and
yet they need to collaborate if we're
going to tackle some of these problems
you've just answered two of the last
three questions I have but I do want to
ask you you know we talked about what
gets you up in the morning and I always
ask my guest is there anything that
keeps you up at night and you've alluded
to a couple of the things that we need
to be concerned about when we're
developing designing and implementing AI
and machine learning technologies and
most people are talking about this idea
of bias and fairness and transparency
but there are other concerns out there
about AI in general some of them are a
bit fantastical Chris what would you say
to the could we call them fear mongers
of AI beyond bias and data so I think
there is another danger that we haven't
talked about but it's not the risk of
superhuman robots taking over the
universe I think that is fantastical and
far-fetched and our best lies you know
many years in the future or at worst lie
as many years in the future so I don't
think we need to worry about that the
very real concerns around bias and
fairness and transparency are incredibly
important but the good news is people
are thinking about it there's a lot of
discussion about this a lot of very
smart researchers are working on this so
I feel good about that not because
they're not hard problems are not
important but at least we are aware of
them when we are talking about them
we're researching the world we're making
progress
there's another danger though that if
there's anything that keeps me up at
night about machine learning and AI
this in some way will have some sort of
bump in the road perhaps it will be
something around bias perhaps it will be
something around privacy perhaps
there'll be some security issue there'll
be something which causes us to turn our
backs on the technology and we would
forego the amazing opportunities which
machine learning can offer us let's say
just in the healthcare space where this
could literally improve the lives and
save lives of countless people around
the world for decades and centuries to
come so I think we have to be very
careful at the same time as we discuss
all the challenges and the risks of the
technology to keep in mind the enormous
potential benefits so that we find the
right balance tell us a bit about your
history Chris how did you come to MSR
and come to lead a lab at MSR the way I
came to join the episode was actually
quite interesting I'd been in the field
of machine learning for six or seven
years something like that and I was an
academic in Birmingham a research
professor and I submitted a proposal to
what's called the Isaac Newton Institute
in Cambridge which is an institute for
mathematical sciences and it runs
six-month research programs and I
proposed a program on neural networks
and machine learning this is back in
1997 and the proposal was accepted and
so I got to bring to Cambridge over a
six-month period essentially all of the
top people in the field of machine
learning at the time and we had a
tremendous time it really was an amazing
six-month research program what was
interesting though was that program
began on the 1st of July in 87 which
happened to be the exact same day that
Microsoft set up its first ever research
lab outside of the US and it chose
Cambridge in the UK is the location for
that lab so I arrived in Cambridge on
the exact same day that Microsoft
research started and so the whole of
Microsoft Research Cambridge came to see
me in a taxi three of them the founding
lab director and a couple of Deputies
came to visit me at the Newton Institute
and said hey we're setting up this lab
and you know we're gonna do all this
great stuff and do you want to join us
and I thought about it for a few
nanoseconds and said yes I've looked
and of course I stayed on to finish the
six-month program so I didn't actually
start working in the lab until the
January but it was an amazingly happy
coincidence and so I've really been at
the MSR Cambridge lab since it began
leading the machine learning group
really helping build the machine
learning group rather than leaving it
for many years and then three years ago
the opportunity rose to become lab
director and that's an exciting and new
and different challenge and I've been
having a lot of fun doing that as we
close perhaps you could give some
parting advice to our listeners many of
whom are just getting started in their
research careers we talked about some of
the most exciting problems and
challenges that you see on the horizon
already what would you tell your 25 year
old self if you were listening to this
podcast I think my top level advice
would be not worry too much about
optimizing your career and planning your
trajectories and paths through different
job opportunities and so on but instead
just go after something that you really
care about because at the end of the day
you'll have much more energy and you
will most likely achieve a lot more and
the career will kind of sort itself out
and especially if you were to feel
anything like machine learning there are
so many opportunities out there that
really just focus on the thing that
really excites you whether it's working
on the algorithms whether it's working
in healthcare whatever it is focus on
the thing that you're most passionate
about and the rest will take care of
itself would 25 year old Chris Bishop
listen to you probably not but I don't
listen to anybody you know what that's
why you're successful in research Chris
Bishop thank you for joining us on the
show today
it's been fun thank you very much
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Christopher
Bishop and the innovative research he
directs at MSR Cambridge visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]